first of all I'm going to start with
congratulations I thought I thought you
this is a really really hard movie to
pull off and I'm just going to say
congrats thank you that's so lovely
thank you for saying that um so I have a
million questions
um how a million how did you decide
which of the iconic moments from the
original film you sort of wanted to
bring and not mess with right which were
the moments you're like I can play with
that one well you know there are certain
iconic moments you know listen we're a
fan of the film too you know original
film just like all the fans that love it
and so we there are things that are
sacred I feel
um just as important as a lyric or even
a line of dialogue you know there are
things you hold on to images that you
hold on to and we knew those we needed
to hold on to those but at the same time
this is a completely different genre so
you're in a live-action form there's so
much more opportunity to expand to
deepen
um to to to actually Infuse with uh true
uh ocean you have real people there and
so that was exciting
um as we started to work on we thought
what what what what can we you know
listen an animated film from 1989 which
is obviously beloved
there that's the bones of what you're
working from but we went directly back
to the Hans Christian Andersen tale
first thing and we found a very
emotional and modern story it was so it
was written almost 200 years ago and so
contemporary and And Timely about a
young girl who feels displaced wants
something different in her life and she
she goes on this epic journey of
self-discovery to break down the
barriers between herself and people that
are different than her you know the
human world and that was very moving to
us that you know she is she is working
to build a bridge to break you know the
the down the wall between her and and
what's and someone that's different than
her and so uh that that that sort of
sense of acceptance and and uh was was
intolerance if you say John was very was
very profound and so so we saw wow we
have an opportunity to do something uh
sort of that has a deeper message this
is a jokey question I would imagine a
lot of people wanted to be in this movie
these are great roles yes so who offered
the best bride
I wish there were no bribes involved at
this point but they're all too
respectful I mean you know our goal when
casting just so you know is that we
never actually ultimately have to even
make a choice it's sort of chosen for us
that's what happened here on every level
with every character these people claim
the roles for themselves first and
foremost with Hallie Hallie you know we
auditioned so many people every
ethnicity every kind of person we could
find I mean it was like literally where
hundreds of people and the and the Irene
of course is the first person that walks
through the door was Halle Bailey she
literally came in
um said would you should I read or sing
first we said we'd love you to do
whatever you'd like she said I'll sing
first she started to she shut her eyes I
remember that
started to sing Part of Your World
and it was so emotional it was so moving
I was in tears at the end you remember
John I was sitting there I was in tears
at the end of this song and I thought
I turned to you John I said is this
Ariel you know but then of course this
beautiful mix of this childlike
innocence and mature strength which was
and and then this other world equality
and then the voice so yeah it's kind of
evident and we thought you know is this
it but we then continue to look and look
and look and look and we and but she'd
set the bar so high she came in many
times too during the process but it was
like no one surpassed that and then and
then we we put her on uh we did a screen
test with her and it was just so obvious
and so once again she claimed the roles
that it really was her it was her
decision she said this is my role I
think a lot of people watching the movie
will not understand the technical
complexities of making this particular
film well that's good in a way I mean I
have to say that was the goal like we
never wanted the the sort of the
technical aspect of the film to lead it
but but if you saw how it was made oh my
lord well I'm assuming at some point
there's going to be like a behind the
scenes documentary because there's no
wonderful ones yes well talk if you
don't mind what was one of the things
that you really truly didn't know how
you were going to solve to make this
film work I I just the legit six of the
whole thing yeah we we wrote an outline
and we came to LA and spent two months
with everyone in this big space all our
creatives yes and we just how are we
going to make the first step
yeah and like this one he's just so
patient and listens to everybody in the
room and we just started having
methodology meetings yes and we found a
way in yes I mean it involved obviously
a blue screen for all the underwater
work and every kind of apparatus you can
possibly imagine a new technique called
anima which is when you when something
that you that's that's too impossible to
actually uh film because it's just too
physical or no one could do it
um that we then applied their face it
was it's it's a it's even different than
motion capture to a moment that was just
too complicated and that was something
that we actually were able to do with
cameras and light
um so that was incredible but planning
yeah every every step of the way since
we would have to map it out in our heads
to decide what we're doing then we had
to teach it the actors work work like
that then we had to teach the stunt
people because all these different
apparatus came with 10 to 20 stun people
that have to breathe and with the actor
know every line and time it like because
it's choreography fee we had so much
prep and so much rehearsal I mean I will
say the most complicated uh piece for me
was under the sea
because you have one live actor and then
it's other but a massive production
number and probably the most important
number in the piece because it's the
oscar-winning film it has I mean Oscar
winning number and so it had to be
something really special and um I
remembered that Walt Disney had worked
with the ballet ruse company when he was
creating Fantasia because they needed to
work from some template some kind of
movement some kind of bodies and so I
thought well you know what that's what
we should do we should work with a
company so we brought the Alvin Ailey
Foundation over to London and we had
them literally uh play all these
different sea creatures I mean this is
an extraordinary dance company and so
every little movement that they did was
trying to replicate these different sea
creatures and we we worked on you know
we had chosen all these amazing
creatures fish and and wonderful
creatures mimic octopus and Olympics and
flatworms and I mean every kind to
create this number and it was that was
that it was using them as a template for
our artist to work from but also all the
storyboard work we did previous work to
make that all come together so that's a
miracle of a musical number I actually
sometimes I watch a movie and the CGI
really pulls me out yes but the CGI in
this is exceptional wow and it really is
that was our goal so that was his goal
from day one so we oh sorry he would
always say this is the most technical
thing we've all ever done the most
important thing is the story we cannot
let that technical exercise lead and so
that was his Mantra that was that well
if you don't mind with the CGI can you
sort of talk about because it it really
does look like you like you put the
camera Under the Sea you know what I
mean and so talk a little bit about how
you pulled that off with the technical
limitations maybe that you were up
against well we have an amazing visual
effects supervisor Tim Burke who
actually LED this extraordinary team of
people we explained what we wanted we
had so that we had illustrations our
production designer John Meyer our
cinematographer we all knew what we were
doing we were all on the same page we
wanted a photo real world we wanted to
believe we were in that world because if
if you believe you're there and it's
part of you know you're you're deep
there in the sea all the things even the
light from the darkest place which is
Ursula's Lair to the the brightest place
which is like that that we called
Ariel's ledge where she meets Scuttle
for the first time in our film like all
of those different like the gradations
of the water it was all so very specific
and uh it was that's why it took four
and a half years I mean it we did not we
did not settle we would not settle we it
had to be at every single moment from a
very clear communication with the
artists every very crucial every Turtle
every fish every moment was disgusted
everything it was it was insane every
strand of air
is added it was insane but but uh it was
like climbing Mount Everest but we but
we felt like you know at least we got
there to put that flag on the top and
that's for sure I have to stop her she's
gonna kill me I'm just going to say
congrats thank you I'm pretty confident
the movie's gonna do well if the box
office oh thank you that's so generous